[Music]
state your name I'm Kathy Hogle I swear
do you solemnly swear that I will
support you I didn't come here to make
history
I came here to make a difference
and to pursue the worthy causes
pursue them together
and as your Governor I'll keep fighting
for you every single day
[Music]
each of the women I mentioned redefine
leadership in their own way and they
paved the way
for others to follow
and to be clear it wasn't just because
they're women but they made their mark
they embodied the courage and the
character that still defines New Yorkers
to this day
and above all they were Fighters
and now as I stand before you humbled by
this honor
I'm ready to take on the fight
[Laughter]
[Music]
New York women have been the
Trailblazers
for the rest of our nation for they
overcame every barrier
to push forward despite all the odds
[Music]
[Applause]